believe me let me tell you there's about
a couple days I wanted to lay in the
fetal position in bed I'm not gonna lie
I'm a strong woman but there's been a
couple days where I just said I don't
want to do this
and God just kicked my butt out of bed
and said get back out there I put you in
this for a reason I didn't put a weak
person in this fight now of course it
seems it would have been easier for God
to prevent all of this if he wanted to
carry a lake to be the governor and just
have her win the damn election but God
works works in mysterious ways and we
don't know who prayed in in contrast and
Counterpoint and the prayer might have
canceled out who the hell knows